les fêtes au grand air des centaines
d'étudiants se retrouvent pour l'une des
dernières soirées de l'été qui dit
festivités 10 mousty parfois abus mais
un groupe presque entièrement composée
de femmes se mobilisent pour les
éliminer qui est saine et sauve et là ce
soir pour prévenir les violences à
caractère sexuel les gens savent pas
vers qui se référer ci arrive quelque
chose donc le but rennais sow c'était
vraiment à être la référence les
personnes ressources
l'organisme à but non lucratif est saine
et sauve sensibilise les participants
dès leurs arrivées n'en avaient été
victimes ou témoins de croître quoi est
il des faits scientifiques etc ok si une
personne vit du harcèlement comme porte
de sortie elle peut toujours se tourner
vers une de leur sentinelle ce soir en
sentinelle parcouru la piste de danse et
les alentours
sans tabou elles font discrètement
plusieurs tournées pendant la soirée on
y va soit ça peut être des moments que
les jeunes sont interpellés at elle
besoin la comprends mais
qui posté à l'entrée
elles font appel aux gardes de sécurité
advenant une situation plus sérieuse ou
dirigent les victimes vers les
professionnels qualifiés une chose est
sûre leur présence rend plusieurs
participantes à l'aise ce genre de
soirée où il prévoit sur deux choses
c'est plus rassurant pour mu y ont leur
place dans tous les événements dès que
michael la consommation implique et un
milan mélangez y est toujours et
consistance depuis mars l'équipe est de
plus en plus présente dans les
événements étudiants elle a été
approchée pour le bal du hec montréal en
mai dernier et ses services sont
demandés pendant les initiations les
sentinelles sont des bénévoles elle
étudie dans les domaines d'intervention
comme en psychologie et en sciences
infirmières est pas encore arrivé les
soirées mon équipe présente qu'il peut
et des gens qui ont suivi harcèlement
sexuel mais on veut aussi agir par
exemple avec les personnes qui sont
intoxiqués que ce soit à l'alcool que ce
soit diverses trucks et créative plus
d'une personne sur trois qui étudient ou
travaillent dans les universités du
québec a déjà vécu une forme de violence
sexuelle selon une étude de 2017 c'est
mieux de faire quelque chose que de rien
faire je pense que en s'alliant avec
saine et sauve ont fait une action pee
wee c'est peut-être pas parfait oui
c'est le début d'un changement mais faut
le faire ce changement de la soirée tire
à sa fin saine et sauve dit déjà avoir
offert du soutien à plusieurs
participants ce soir par exemple c'est
surtout des témoins qui sont venus lui
relater des événements qui sont passés
sur la piste de danse l'organisme espère
qu'un jour ces services deviendront
inutiles mais force lui est d'admettre
qu'elle devra encore patienter ici
charles du boullay radio canada montréal